good morning believe nation if you want
to have a lot of success with your
business with your idea then it's
important that you're not just trying to
do something to make a lot of money but
you're standing for something important
I'm going to share with you a great clip
from Robert Johnson that I think will
help as most of you know I have always
been vocal about economic opportunity
for African Americans I am what you
might call a serial entrepreneur I get a
vision about something that should be
done usually in an area where
african-americans are economically and
underrepresented and I try my best to
create a business solution to help
address these social and economic
problems so Robert Johnson is worth over
half a billion dollars he's done it all
through creating businesses that support
that's applaud that support the black
community and what he's done is he
believes that black people have equal
rights and should have equal
opportunities and he looks for markets
where block people are underrepresented
and he creates a business there and he's
been ultra successful doing it and my
business I've done the same thing to
help entrepreneurs I feel like
entrepreneurs are not well represented
there isn't enough quality information
to help entrepreneurs out and so that's
why I started doing what I'm doing just
look at YouTube as an example right I
believe that entrepreneurs are
underrepresented on YouTube YouTube is
full of stupid tricks cat videos music
videos where is the helpful educational
valuable motivating resources for
entrepreneurs there wasn't much out
there's a few people doing some great
things but as a whole entrepreneur's you
look at how many people want to start a
business look at how many people are
trying to start their company get it off
the ground and look at the compare that
to the amount of videos that are on
YouTube entrepreneurs are
underrepresented and that's why I
started doing what I'm doing even this
morning series that you're watching now
I wish somebody actually else created it
I needed it for myself because it didn't
exist it was so underrepresented for
entrepreneurs that that's why I started
this and it's had success
so in your business you need to do the
same thing you got to stand for
something you got to stand up for
community you got to say listen we need
more of this and I'm going to help
provide it because it's valuable and
it's needed in this community and when
you stand for something important and
you're providing tremendous value to
community I promise you you're going to
make a lot of money so my question of
the day for you today is what are you
staying for I want to know what you
stand for as an entrepreneur leave it in
the comments below i'm going to join in
the discussion tell me in those comments
what do you stand for and if you like
this video and you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and the newsletter thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of awesomeness
to kick start your day